[Music]
so this 24 year old here named
justin one day he was walking home from
uh i don't know from work but oh wait
from work sorry he was elementary school
and when all of a sudden he was struck
by lightning by a motorcycle
oh oh [ __ ] yeah why was he walking in
the middle of the street
i don't know where he was walking it was
in july i don't know if it was
that's all i know about the accident and
the impact
severed his right leg oh my god
and it sent him to the hospital and then
to rehab
for months that's something like he lost
his leg yeah
he lost his leg and so
when he's trying to like process this
and dealing with this and like
having no longer a right leg
he thought that the best way for him to
cope with all this and for him to grieve
of like
with the loss of his leg he wanted to
get his
leg taxidermied i wanted
to like save his leg and keep his legs
that's an
option interesting i've never heard of
that i've seen people do that because
they
they it's easier to cope with it being
like this so like a leg
you just have a leg statue in your house
and you're just like that's my leg
or there's the the fetish people that
are like
i'm totally kidding i don't know i'm
like if you know
tell me
but yeah so he decided that that was
just how he wanted to grieve and that
was his way of getting closure
and so is he also gonna buy a motorcycle
and put her next to the lake
[Laughter]
it's a panorama people have to go to
like where the accident happened to
get over it oh yeah you know sometimes
yeah that's true
people have different ways of coping
with things yeah i saw this mountain
biker that had a crazy accident and he
[ __ ] up his like body from it and then
he made a video
going back to the same place and
conquering that downhill mountain oh
thank god
and i was scared for him like dude with
an accident that crazy i wouldn't go
back to the same place i'd be like i'm
gonna
take it from 10 to like one imagine
going back to the same place
filming yourself [ __ ] it up again
[Laughter]
this year it's like part three oh that's
terrible
my friend did something similar my
friend i'll take talk uh he's afghan guy
he got shot in the
in the back of the neck oh [ __ ] he got
the altercation or the guy trying point
blank like right here
he died on the scene but it was like a
new rookie uh emt that was like no like
i'm not giving up
and brought his heart beat back wow yeah
everyone else said no he's dead they
were telling the other guy to get off
him
good thing it wasn't the old grizzled
emt i know like i've seen it a million
times he's deader than a door
he just shot a a new uh he's a rapper he
made his new
rap video at the scene of the the crime
it was like top five on uh
the whole album was like did you get the
emt in the music video for a cameo
the guy who saved his life or brought
him back from the dead that's crazy
damn did he say what it's like to die i
don't know
well there's it's all obviously just the
heartbeat
because nobody's came back from the
brain dead but it's just regular
heartbeat but i don't know i didn't ask
him
maybe he's experienced himself because
just yesterday we talked about um
a lot of people having their their
experiences and like how they just felt
like
warm and calm there's a new netflix show
about it yeah
yeah but yeah i've done some like
research on it
but but miracle sign but it's all just
their heartbeat stops and that you could
bring back
right crazy well back to justin here
so it actually took them months of
coordination
and hundreds of emails and dozens of
phone calls
and just a little bit of internet magic
and that's how he
finally was able to get his leg treated
but there were just so many text jeremy
places that were like
no way there's no way we're [ __ ]
doing this and it even took convincing
from
uh to convince the hospital to release
it it's because
my leg [ __ ] give it to me
what were they gonna do but like sorry
it's not yours anymore we don't know
what you're gonna do with it like why
would you want this it's gonna go rotten
no yeah it's my leg [ __ ] that's why
isn't it his leg legally
um i think when when something happens
like that i don't know what i mean
i'd be blessed if if my dick fell off
and they're like we need it for science
and i'm like [ __ ] that's my dick it's
contaminated waste
about science it's more of a being a
hazardous waste now
and there has to be there's like laws
and procedures where they have to be
properly disposed yeah but if my cat
dies right
that's my [ __ ] cat it'll give you the
body just to
[ __ ] off i want to bury it my way hey
can you just bury your pet in your
backyard
so like your body part is not yours
anymore that's mind-blowing well it's
it's still like you just have to go
through some some
like what is it hoops you have to go
through hoops to actually get your body
part back look at the whole hospital
well you get a when you get a haircut
you can't even get your hair back
it's on the ground that's true i if
no one's gonna stop me though i get a
[ __ ] dustpan and go this is
mine [ __ ] dude but that's all hazardous
waste though
like at the hospital you have to sign
paperwork to make sure that the hospital
is not liable for whatever the [ __ ]
you're going to do with this
why is the human leg my [ __ ] body
parts hostage they
like they don't put random people in
like a surgery room they brought us with
meatloaf was [ __ ] the
projectile vomiting
they brought us in the room just to look
at him he's projecting out vomiting all
his food because he went through like he
ate like a whole
bottle of medicine and so it's
completely different at a vet
compared to like actual oscar there's
way more cleanliness and like procedures
that they don't let you into random
rooms
yeah and i i guess i shouldn't say
hazardous waste is biological waste yeah
that's the better term yeah waste speak
for yourself that's my leg
dude i've seen a severed leg in person
how big was it it was a
full-grown man's leg it was up to the
hip or to the knee or oh it was was it
fresh
it was a neat yeah just removed was it a
different color because
you know how when things get severed
it's like not even human anymore just
yeah it starts dying
yeah it's weird man well i don't i don't
know what it was supposed to be
but it just looks like meat it's [ __ ]
wild everything just looks like meat
when you cut it
so yeah and so he had to get um so he
had to coordinate between
like the hospital and being like okay
yeah i think it's okay we'll let you
have it
and then after the hospital released his
leg then he had to coordinate with a
funeral home to pick up his leg and
handle
his leg to transport it to the this
place that
like he actually finds found some place
that agreed to do it and they
should do it he found some loophole that
if i get it from the hospital to the
funeral home
then i can take possession like there
and that's all legal
yeah like he had to figure custody yeah
exactly
and this whole time he's like limping
there or yeah he didn't have a leg this
whole time that's what he was saying he
was like hopping around
like on phone calls he was like give me
back my [ __ ] leg [ __ ]
yeah so this whole time he didn't he
didn't build a new robot leg or one of
those things
like that well this is within days right
if it's like months or
months oh he could have had time to
build his own robot leg
he could have been to leg depot or
something there got to be a leg storm no
it took months because
a lot of people said no and like there
was this other like taxidermy place
where they were charging him
fifteen thousand dollars like this is a
quote from the actual place that
ended up it's just his life giving the
go ahead
human things are way harder taxidermy
than
animals really yeah because it's not
it's skin it's not [ __ ] just fur and
like
yeah but they text dirty [ __ ] pigs so
this is
okay so the prehistoria natural history
center
aka pnhc in downtown
toronto agreed to do to treat his leg
for
justin and so this is what they said um
i just want this dude to have his leg
i know and he he did it's a happy ending
but let me get there
do they put lotion on it no because i'll
show you okay
you don't want to ask your knee in the
living room we actually had heard that
he had reached out to a taxi derby
studio who quoted him fifteen thousand
dollars to do his leg now for a frame of
reference what fifteen thousand dollars
should get you in terms of bone
preparation i would charge
that much to take an entire dead whale
off a beach
tear it down to bone and mount it so
they were robbing them yeah
so then he says so yeah it was quite an
outrageous request for that much money
so for us it seemed like it was just
something we could give back so they
didn't charge him at all
wow that is awesome dude
yeah and so here i'll finally show you
guys if someone charged me 15 g's for my
own name i'm like you just keep it then
this is what it's like now after being
treated by
oh i thought he was gonna do it like a
full-on deer with it still
i thought he was taxidermy in yeah
bone preparation because how are you
gonna have the skin and [ __ ] that's why
i thought it took damage
to them to figure out that's why it cost
15 grand
you never seen a [ __ ] deer on a wall
yeah
or deer it's not bone it's not deer bone
that's fur though
i don't know he got it done in texas he
could have just buried it and came back
a few years later
in toronto true i don't know man
no but like it has to still be treated a
certain way and like to put in glass to
make it
like the bone whiter and to mount it
just bleach that just leave it in bleach
leave it in bleach
it's actually peroxide hydrogen
peroxidase
and then this is the team that helped
him preserve his legs
thanks dinosaur team and some other
stuff over here yo he got a new leg
though huh
um robot leg that's tight i don't know
got a robot leg in there i think those
are some just some loose jeans there
oh but yeah so it took justin a whole
bunch of months i would have been so
pissed if my leg came back with low
quality
like at the hospital i'm like what did
you do to my leg you [ __ ]
dude i'm going through something kind of
similar a little bit because i can
we have i have a carpet and i've taken
to so many
different dry cleaning places and nobody
will [ __ ] clean rug yeah why
does it got a lot of [ __ ] stains it just
has a cat piece stain on it that's it
they're like i ain't touching that and
they can't treat it they can't trust you
like
we don't do that here and i'm like what
the [ __ ] you guys don't you feel like
you understand what he went through
yo i try to tell him that it's you could
take carpet to the dry cleaners
yes dry cleaners oh [ __ ] i didn't know
that you have to like
find out the smell is painful when you
smell it's like it's not great but i
don't think that's why they're not doing
it i think they're just like we don't
do that what if we take it to the car
wash and put on top of the car
why don't you just call one of those
carpet people to come to your house yeah
carpet people
carpet cleaners what do you mean carpet
but they come clean your carpets right
harvardmunchers.com oh [ __ ] i didn't
think of that yeah that's pretty sick
but they're spency right i mean so are
the dry cleaner places because i i got a
quote
for a rug that we were trying i was
trying to keep but then ultimately i got
rid of it but yeah there was like a
little
stain on it and i called the carpet like
a dry cleaning place who did
do rugs like they do clean rugs and
it was pretty pricey you gotta do all
dad dude just get your carpet
get the hose spray that [ __ ] down put
some comment
scrub it in with the toothbrush it
depends if it has dyes in it this is
like a
carpet that nikki got ordered from like
another country and i don't even can't
even [ __ ] with it with chemicals
oh like that yeah it's like a leather
that's probably that's when you call
your cats
that's how it sounds when it comes out
of that [ __ ]
you